a 300 billion
coven 19 relief bill falling short in
the senate after every single democrat
voted against the republican plan
and congressional correspondent chad
pergram is live on capitol hill chad the
loss was not a surprise no everybody
pretty much knew which direction this
was going to go keep in mind this was
not a straight up or down vote on
coronavirus relief this was an effort to
break a filibuster
democrats were filibustering this piece
of legislation you need 60 votes to
crack a filibuster
the vote today was 52-47 republicans are
not pleased with democrats blocking this
let's start with lindsey graham
republican of south carolina
people are hurting out there and it
seems to me that my democratic
colleagues have stuck on a number
they think it's better for them to deny
a
deal to trump than it is to pass a bill
that would help people
and that's very unfortunate even though
they needed 60 yays for this there were
questions as to whether or not senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell could
coax at least 51 senators on his side of
the aisle to vote yes
mcconnell was coy yesterday that he may
not have had 51 gop votes then but he
had them today
52 republican kentucky senator rand paul
was the only gop nay
republicans failed to get any democrats
to cross over
this emaciated bill is not a serious
attempt
at legislation or solving the real
problems in our country it's a shame
it is one of the most cynical moves i've
seen
now there are a lot of questions right
now as to whether or not getting any
sort of coronavirus bill is dead until
after the election i pressed house
speaker nancy pelosi
on that point this morning she said no
but she is adamant dana that she doesn't
want to attach
any coronavirus relief to any bill to
fund the government they have to do that
before october first back to you
time is ticking away thank you chad